et
[Musique]
bienvenue pour cette édition du 7 8 les
invités chaque jour du lundi au jeudi
rendez vous avec celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans le département des
yvelines est aujourd'hui le mardi 27
septembre vous entendrez philippe
brillault c'est un maire en colère l'élu
du chesnay également conseiller
départemental s'inquiètent de l'arrivée
des migrants sur 50 sur son canton jean
yves petit directeur de la prévention
routière dans les yvelines nous ferons
avec lui un point sur les derniers
chiffres et puis il nous présentera
cette application securid rise un nouvel
outil interactif de mise en situation
avant de prendre la route et puis avec
olivier corps d'un nous verrons qu'il
est possible de sortir avec bbc même le
nom de son site internet ou comment
conserver une vie sociale lorsque l'on
devient parent et pour débuter retour
donc sur cette polémique qui s'installe
l'installation des camps de migrants
dans le département plusieurs sites sont
envisagés et notamment sur le canton du
chesnay le maire de cette commune par
ailleurs conseiller départemental a
réuni en fin de semaine dernière les
élus qui sont dans les communes alentour
pour contester les choix du gouvernement
et surtout le manque de consultation des
populations locales écoutez philippe
briand il est entouré de deux côtés un
par l'autoroute de l'ouest et de l'autre
côté par la départementale c'est un site
extrêmement dangereux d'ailleurs le vous
savez qu'il y à une discothèque et qui
est juste là qui est extrêmement
dangereuse en sortie le soir le jour
donc ça veut dire que les migrants s'ils
sont situés là ne pourront avoir que les
transports en commun pour rejoindre non
pas paris mais vers sa yourte donc on a
un vrai sujet d'accès déjà dans un
premier temps le deuxième au niveau du
confort c'est qu'en fait ce sont des
bâtiments modulaires qui à mon avis mans
a mené sur ce terrain est donc là n'est
pas le problème en fait nous avons aussi
un sujet c'est que c'est un terrain
privé sur lequel le maire négocié avec
l'état tout un aménagement et que c'est
une remise en cause de cet aménagement
donc c'est vrai que quelque part on est
assez étonné de cette je dirais facilité
d'utilisation 28 hectares pour une
centaine de migrants donc effectivement
on est un peu surpris de cette annonce
brutale que nous avons eus je dirais
parfitt âge faut pas se leurrer et c'est
vrai qu'il ya aujourd'hui dans la
population on sent un c'est pas une
interrogation c'est une grande forte et
je pense que si le gouvernement ne fait
pas attention ce sera l'étincelle qu'ils
ont pu éviter à la rentrée et qui
pourrait la voir le jour je crois que
les solutions ne sont pas uniquement sur
le terrain de sienne entre paris la
scène puisque madame hidalgo de vue puis
migre ans et qu'elle veut les mettre
chez nous en demandant au préfet de
région probablement de faire le
nécessaire eh bien il ya un peu de temps
on a besoin de mettre en route un peu
tout cela puisque c'est à peu près 400
places qui sont attendus dans les
yvelines par le préfet le préfet doit
rendre des comptes aussi rapidement donc
on ne peut pas le mettre non plus en
difficulté il faut qu'on réfléchisse
sachant que l'intégration d'immigrants
se fait intelligemment et pas de les
parquer comme c'est prévu dans un
terrain et nous revenons sur notre
antenne cette semaine sur l'accueil des
migrants dans notre rendez vous le 7 8
débat l'association versailles familles
à venir contre cette idée face à la
ligue des droits de l'homme qui défend
les réfugiés c'est à retrouver sur notre
antenne et en replay également dès mardi
soir sécurité routière à présent cette
rentrée l'organisme sécurité routière
lance une nouvelle campagne de
sensibilisation face aux dix tracteurs
de conduite les dix tracteurs ce sont
ces films que l'on regarde sur la
tablette ou encore l'e mail auquel on
répond tout cela en conduisant bien
évidemment alors que de son côté la
prévention routière organise une
consultation nationale autour des
dangers de la route et c'est le
directeur de l'antenne des yvelines que
je reçois ce soir à jean yves petit
bonsoir conçoit prévention routière
sécurité routière également tous les
acteurs sont mobilisés est ce à dire que
les chiffres sont mauvais et que la
situation est préoccupante en cette
rentrée alors les chiffres sont mauvais
depuis deux ans le gouvernement a
largement communiqué là-dessus
nous constatons une légère amélioration
au mois d'août qui fait que globalement
nous sommes à peu près au même niveau
que l'année dernière donc c'est pas pire
que l'année dernière mais c'est
évidemment pas mieux non plus et
concernant uniquement le département des
yvelines cette fois ci alors pour le
département les yvelines
nous étions l'année dernière un peu
meilleur que le que la moyenne nationale
en 2015 nous avons déploré 42 tués et
pour 2016 nous sommes à peu près au même
niveau que 2015 et nous déplorons à ce
jour 31 tués dans le département dont
trois la semaine dernière en
présentation j'évoquais tout à l'heure
cette consultation nationale qui est
menée par la prévention routière à
travers le site internet notamment avec
un petit questionnaire ça va servir à
quoi ça sert à mobiliser à mobiliser les
gens à recueillir leur avis et leur
faire prendre conscience de toutes les
conduites à risques et puis après à
utiliser pour nous pour notre siège pour
porter les revendications auprès des
pouvoirs publics l'actualité de la
prévention routière c'est aussi ses
currys drive un module interactif pour
comprendre les risques liés au mauvais
comportement ça consiste en quoi comment
ça marche on va en voir les images de
cette application oui alors c'est comme
vous le dites une application que l'on
peut trouver par internet ou par
smartphone qui mêle l'utilisateur dans
les principales conditions de conduite à
risque il y à une application fait un
petit exercice sur le soleil 1 sur
l'alcool 1 sur la vitesse et le dernier
sur le téléphone au volant donc j'ai
d'ailleurs des images qui passent là on
voit par images de synthèse on demande à
rondot demande à l'utilisateur de
de rédiger un sms en même temps qui
conduit effectivement évidemment vie
pour le faire ôter les faux pas le faire
en conduite a bien sûr et puis à la même
chose pour l'alcool
le sommeil puisque ya beaucoup d'idées
sur la fatigue au volant et la vitesse
le téléphone au volant cela concerne un
accident de la route sur dix la
somnolence est la première cause de
mortalité sur la route également 2011 la
tendance sur au tour sur autoroute
pardon effectivement 2014 3 118
personnes qui ont perdu la vie pour
s'être assoupi le message c'est avant
tout de la précaution de la prévoyance
que vous essayez de faire passer à pas
sensibiliser l'entourage aussi oui bien
sûr toute façon c'est essentiellement
sur autoroute que ça arrive comme vous
l'avait dit et sur autoroute où le monde
connaît les messages et moi le message
que enfin la chose que je voudrais
ajouter c'est que le meilleur moyen de
faire disparaître la fatigue c'est d'y
céder on s'arrête d'or un quart d'heure
on va prendre un café mais on n'essaie
pas d'en d'ouvrir la fenêtre ou de boire
un verre d'eau tout ça ça vous met la
radio ça marchera peut-être quelques
secondes voire quelques minutes mais la
fatigue reviendra très rapidement pour
revenir sur le dispositif sécurisé drive
vous vous adressez à quel type de public
plutôt les jeunes justement où sa
conservera encore tout le monde alors ça
concerne évidemment tout le monde mais
on vise plutôt les jeunes quand on fait
les applications par internet ou par
smartphone c'est évidemment plus tôt les
jeunes qui sont concernés bien sûr
j'ouvre juste une parenthèse le mondial
de l'automobile va s'ouvrir à paris ce
week end porte de versailles forcément
c'est un moment où on regarde les belles
voitures les voitures qui roulent vite
aussi est-ce que le message de
prévention passe là aussi lors
d'événements comme le mondial de l'auto
prévention maintient la présente par
exemple loyer vous seront présents nous
serons présents le premier jour le 1er
octobre alors ce sera pas les yvelines
évidemment ce sera mes collègues de
paris avec un événement centré sur la
moto
l'officier qui vous inquiète plus qu'il
vous préoccupez la moto oui enfin prend
uniquement la prévention routière mais
le le la part de motards victimes
d'accidents de la route est très
importante c'est plus d'un quart des
tués sur la route et c'est beaucoup plus
que la moyenne européenne votre
association intervient régulièrement on
entre dans une période de début de
campagne électorale il ya des messages à
faire passer j'imagine que l'association
sera plutôt active quels sont les axes
sur lesquels vous allez insisté vos axes
de travail pour les prochains mois alors
le
principal axe de travail d'ici la fin de
l'année c'est le nôtre opération qui
s'appelle 0 enfants tués sur les routes
j'en avais déjà parlé à votre antenne au
printemps quand on a lancé ça le constat
est que
la sécurité sur les routes s'améliore
depuis dix ans globale non mais pour les
enfants ça change pas douze enfants sont
victimes d'accidents de la route chaque
jour et depuis dix ans ça bouge pas donc
notre association a essayé de mobiliser
la population en signant un manifeste
par internet par les réseaux sociaux etc
de façon à
appuyer les cinq revendications les cinq
propositions que nous allons transmettre
à la fin de l'année aux pouvoirs publics
non seulement français mais aussi
européens merci jean yves petit nous
allons refermer cette édition du 7 8 les
invités avec un sujet plus léger pour
retrouver toutes les informations
concernant ses currys driver toute
l'actualité de la prévention routière il
ya bien sûr ce site internet et puis
votre antenne qui est basée également
sur versailles dans le département des
giroflées viroflay alors on a choisi la
voie des salons pas avec ses dires au
fleix merci jean yves petit enfer on
parle d'un sujet plus léger
effectivement à présent comment
maintenir une vie sociale lorsque l'on
devient parent indien pour répondre à
cette question un site internet vient
d'être lancé par de jeunes papas saint
quentinois je sors avec bébé points
comme cette nouvelle adresse web mise en
ligne et voici quelques semaines permet
d'évaluer restaurants centres
commerciaux et musées en fonction de
leur capacité à accueillir de très
jeunes enfants rencontre avec l'un des
papas derrière cette idée olivier corps
d'un c'est ainsi qu'est né de meutre et
de nos expériences en tant que parent
les bonnes expériences les mauvaises
expériences quand on voulait sortir avec
nos enfants on a eu des expériences qui
était très bonne on est allé dans des
endroits on avait tous les services
adaptés de quoi changer un bébé de quoi
nourrir notre db convenablement et
d'autres endroits où nous sommes allés
on ne pouvait pas rentrer avec une
poussette où il y avait de nombreux
escaliers pas d'ascenseur patch sbb dans
des restaurants donc on veut mettre le
bébé dans sur une banquette par exemple
des choses comme ça donc on a on a
discuté ensemble et on est venu avec mon
arrivée avec cette idée de créer un
espace où les parents pourra échanger
partager leur expérience pour pouvoir en
fait
se donner ces retours d'expérience se
dire où
quels sont les bons endroits qu'elles
sont les mauvais endroit où il pouvait
aller ou valait mieux éviter d'aller et
donc on s'est intéressé aux restaurants
aux hôtels hôtels campings bed and
breakfast aux centres commerciaux où je
devais choisir donc des parcs des parcs
de jeux et aussi au niveau culturel au
niveau des musées des châteaux et des
choses comme ça donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de toucher tout l'ensemble en
fait des lieux dans lesquels des parents
profs seront on a officiellement lancé
le site internet le 6 juillet dernier
donc depuis depuis lors on travaille à
augmenter l'audience et augmenter le
nombre d'établissements référence notre
cible c'est zénon saisir vraiment le 04
aucun besoin particulier après 4 ans les
enfants peuvent s'asseoir s'asseoir sur
des chaises normale peuvent manger des
menus enfants mais avant ils ont des
besoins un peu plus particulier donc
c'est ça vraiment qui nous intéresse
c'est important de toucher plus de
parents possible et voilà d'arriver à
aussi à faire en sorte que les
professionnels qui n'ont pas forcément
les capacités d'accueil pour le moment
se rendre compte qu'il ya un besoin il
ya un marché et que ça va aider coup
d'investir dessus donc par exemple des
chaînes d'hôtels qui n'offrent pas de
près de lits de bébé par exemple se
rendre compte que c'est bien d'avoir
dans son hôtel deux ou trois lits
disponibles à prêter en cas de besoin de
des restaurants qui n'ont pas de siège
bébé qui achètent un réhausseur un siège
bébé a proposé c'est l'idée c'est
d'améliorer la situation pour les
parents en leur donnant des informations
c'est vraiment un site participatif donc
tout est modéré il ya aucun avis qui est
publié sans que nous les ayons dû nous
ayons modéré vérifier les informations
au niveau des adresses au niveau des
contacts des choses comme ça donc on
fait attention à vraiment avoir une
vraie modération à faire attention que
les lieux soient bien placés sur les
cartes google ce qui n'est pas toujours
le cas sur internet pendant on est
vraiment ouvert aux utilisateurs et aux
avis les utilisateurs et on permet aussi
aux professionnels qui le veulent de
s'inscrire sur le site là aussi c'est
gratuit ils peuvent le faire ils peuvent
à donner des informations que les
clients n'ont pas forcément pour ces des
informations complémentaires c'est tous
des dons qui peuvent le faire et se
retrouver sur notre site en étant
visible en devenant visible pour des
parents pour permettre leur permettre de
se mettre en avant pour
favoriser la venue des parents il a
vocation à ces temps de toute façon le
site est pas limitée n'est pas limité on
peut rajouter des établissements partout
on a même à l'étranger donc on a trois
quatre établissements à new york on en
est en espagne une en italie en en
grande bretagne en suisse les gens quand
ils se déplacent bas ils peuvent mettre
les avis partout où ils vont c'est la
fin du set 8 les invités pour
aujourd'hui replay sur notre site
internet tv fil 78 points comme nouvelle
édition demain 18h45 en attendant les
programmes se poursuivre
[Musique]